b b real quick a little housekeeping
June 28th I'm going to be in Eerie
Pennsylvania at the Warner Theater July
6th 2024 I am going to be at the Mirage
in Las Vegas this is all new material
guys July 17 2024 I'll be in Edmonton
Alberta Canada The Great Outdoors Comedy
Festival with the Great Outdoors z b
Cher I have a new special out it is on
of.tv this is only fan streaming TV
service where all the uncensored comedy
is where the cool kids are now so just
go to
of.tv Whitney you'll see my special
mouthy and then the two roasts that we
made for only fans that are
wild I went for the crazy I love it I
want to have fun um I want to look more
interesting you look like a divorced
pirate I just raided a pirates's closet
yeah you look like a pirate side check
pirate group who got like one like got
you got like one necklace I'm like we
fucked he won't tell you we fucked but
we fucked yeah you're like wearing one
of the like Nets from the boat as in
your walk of
shame I'm a pirate only
fans um all right let me get rid of like
three of these hold on these are what
mental illness is this do you know
that's what I was I said this is ADHD
but like beautiful but like with OCD
yeah and like a lot of people have OCD
or ADHD I have both everything is like
compulsively but it's all like spread
out beautifully is this water bottle in
Albatross and is this yours or is this
oh this is like merch sorry or like what
is it called um also should we get rid
of the baby bottle should you just drink
it and not say anything throughout
the just like anyway I during every how
has motherhood Chang me that is
gross oh you drank it I think I got a
little looks like you're recycl
oh my God holy
shit I think I'm really going to throw
up I'm not even kidding I don't know if
it was the suckling of like it feeling
like a micropenis was in my mouth hot
it's
lukewarm like it tastes like Luke some
guy named
Luke from
Tampa that was a very specific there was
like a like a sweat in ck1 undertone to
that oh warm L I love how no one told
you to do that no no one dared you like
you floated it and I was like I don't
want her to think I'm not game for a bit
you go I'm fucking fun I don't want her
to think that just because I have a kid
now I'm not down to
clown oh my God I need female Comics to
know that I play ball that was funny
last night though when you're like we
weren't it was I we don't have to hang
are we rolling all out myself yeah last
night I did something downright
Shady well here's the thing I I I love
making new girlfriends but I don't have
any
room kick one out or time you have to
sacrifice one so I yeah yeah one's got
to go so you and Annie Letterman are
going to have to you're going to have to
fight in my backyard should we do a
boxing match like a YouTube boxing yeah
for sure only fans only fans let's stay
on brand here yes I don't do you want to
see those comments on YouTube no I don't
look at them I'm not allowed to oh I
wouldn't wait me and Annie that would be
so fun you're not allowed to look at
YouTube I don't look at comments ever
who disallows you my husband he's very
controlling that's hot no but he for my
mental health I wouldn't be here if I
looked at comments you're like I don't
look at YouTube comments my husband
yells at me not to and that helps my
mental health I go would I rather have a
fight with my husband or a fight with
100 imaginary trolls what would happen
if you looked at them if I look at them
then you could potentially get upset and
then he looks at me and he's like why
are you upset and then I have to be like
I looked at the comments and he goes
That's a you problem cuz we don't do
that in this household he's a comic too
you guys have a
house an
apartment house is a strong word we
don't do that in this apartment we don't
do that in this apartment in this one
bedroom it doesn't have the same
Authority does it get out of my
apartment
um okay so good news is that he still
asks you why you're
upset this is great news good news we
talk to each other but not to get too
deep I really realize that if you read
the comments and then you start caring
about it then it affects your creativity
and once they affect your creativity
then they
win okay so you just want to post freely
and not care about the feedback I'm an
artist yes and you don't want to harm
your craft exactly we wouldn't want to
compromise The Muse of my dick jokes
yeah yeah exactly
so here's what I'll
say about the comment thing I I just are
they that upsetting no I've I've
actually been pretty good the last
couple years yeah are they only
upsetting when you kind of agree with
them you know what it is I did real TV
for a second and that was a different
level of fandom where they were like
commenting on things that like weren't
really how they happened and that's when
I have trouble on summer house you
actually were in a house then I once
didn't last long they were like go back
to your stupid little
apartment so okay you were on summer
house and then you had fans from that
they're very involved very involved in a
good way or bad way both so like I've
had points in reality TV where like
people loved me they were like she's a
relatable hilarious queen and the
reality TV where they're like women are
crazy and whatever it's just like like
whatever the storyline is best for That
season but you become something people
project on to in any whenever you're a
public figure or any any we're all
projecting on everybody all the time
you're right but like here's the what I
will say about negative comments is
someone that has had a fraught past with
them and has lost weeks to like deep
suicidal depression after seeing one
misspelled
comment you know what I mean I recommend
I highly recommend it like why do you it
was like the Twitter egg it wasn't even
a real person it was just like you not
funny and I was
like oh my God I guess I have to be Bic
again like that was me yeah do you know
what I mean like I were you're younger
than me but it's like I we've there's
always been some iteration of this right
like when I was younger like we didn't
like troll people on the internet we
didn't bully people we didn't like
damage them psychologically we like
damaged their property like we would
take shovels for a kid we didn't like in
school and like drive past and like
smash their mailbox illegal
illegal fully a crime crime we committed
crimes against people that we didn't
like instead of just being you suck like
I would have preferred but you're a real
one we would egg people's homes we would
we would pants people like we would pull
their pants sexually assault off in like
public we would destroy them from we
made School shooters from
scratch do you know what I'm saying yeah
they didn't plant it on some Cloud yeah
no no no no like we made someone's
perception of themselves was destroyed
forever you know and now people are like
you suck and everyone's like I can't go
on so you're saying real peace is like
don't be that affected by the comments
period if you accidentally see one why
are we making it such a big dealone is
mad at you you've made it if any
stranger is mad at you or doesn't like
you it just means you made it I do think
if no one is saying anything negative
about you none of people know who you
are yeah and I think for one negative
comment there's like 500 people this is
a real statistic uh of a scientist that
were just like love her love her
speaking of scientists do you know that
I attended your New York screening of
your movie at the
wing I don't remember the details but I
was there cuz I worked for like a
millennial like company and I walked up
to you afterwards and I was like thank
you for being a female director you're
really important and you were so nice
and I just remember thinking like when
he's a genius and now full circle here
we are I love you for saying that no
that movie was so sick and I just
remember not even knowing that you
direct and I was like she can do
everything that's so nice of you I made
a movie about Neuroscience it was so
good before people cared about narosa
you before your time this was I'm always
it's called being
irrelevant before like I'm like relevant
people didn't know women had brains when
you did that I made a movie called the
female brain and everyone was like uh
that's a fantasy this just a horror
movie sci-fi
sci-fi I don't want to see aliens I just
want to romcom Whitney is this anime
yeah this is a fiction movie she's lost
her fucking mind no it was it's such a
good movie people don't talk about it
enough well yeah now it's like there's
no gender I'm like okay all right the
fact that I implied that like there's
any kind saying the word female toxic
toxic well why you know like the only
problem with female to me is when a guy
is like let's go hang out with some
females why is that when if a guy says
female on a podcast everyone gets upset
it's contextual because you know he's
about to say something about a body
count right which is one of the
questions that someone sent in for you
on my Instagram which is why you're here
today which is what they said what's her
body count I love that question because
first of all I'm not a fucking
loser second all I put up numbers like I
think research is important sure sure
been to seen your frogs Yeah they wanted
all women to be virgins so we couldn't
compare dicks and compare lovers and I'm
not a fucking idiot so I'm going to put
research in I'm a scientist and in order
to understand all the STDs I need to
have them you know actually I'm not out
here being like yeah I love dick I love
dick it's like I'm actually someone
who's had a lot of ups and downs in
sexual experience I'm not like crazy
confident in sex that's not why I'm not
showing off about how like tight my
pussy is even though she is so fucking
tight it's it's about showing that like
I'm having human experiences on this
Earth with sex and we don't have to hide
it I have so much I hold on this is the
quiet I she's have you ever seen me I
can't tell is this going badly I need
to she's like can you leave it's
actually going too well dare I say
normally within like 2 minutes I'm like
bitch I got this let me just I'll handle
it I just feel like sex overall the way
it's talked about the way it's shown in
the media is like the always the hottest
scene it's steamy she's like orgasming
100 times his dick is so fucking hard
all he's not even like making eye
contact and it's like perfectly going in
like and he jeans on he hasn't even
unzipped his jeans and they're fucking I
basically was like I'd rather wait to
like know a person and make sure I koky
trust them a little and then maybe I
could come maybe I could come there I
have to feel like a little bit safe and
that's why like when we're on our own
we're just like coming I have to feel
like I'm incredibly safe and then once I
feel safe I have to pretend you're
murdering Me In Cold Blood that that's
so layered and that is the female brain
that's girlhood you know what I'm saying
it's like I have to feel super safe and
then I have to pretend you're um gashing
me with a meat hook it's so funny cuz
I'm I'm not like that where like if he
even accidentally scratches me with like
his hand like Crossing I will be like ow
oh no ow you're just over on some
princess in the PE shit during sex like
you're just like or he's like de SL and
I'm like I am like college educated well
first of all do you think I'm little
thank you first of all thank you I like
don't care to be disrespected in bed
interesting I always say like if I want
to feel bad in bed just like look me in
the eye and say you're disappointed in
me you know and then I'll want to make
you come see I don't want to be
disrespected at spin class
see I want to be disrespectful I want
them to be like you lazy piece of shit
and I'll be like I'll be good for you I
want to hear that in bad where did our
lives take a turn that I went in this
direction cuz well as an I was a tennis
player and growing up abuse it's all
like but I mean good it's the abuse
where it's like I'm going to be a
champion cuz I'm working harder than the
other person like we would do planks on
hardcourts in Florida and like your
Skin's just peeling off and you're like
I'm a champion yeah yeah yeah yeah so
like it was just about like numbing your
feelings and just pushing through and
that's where I think I get my work ethic
from but it wasn't enjoyable but where
did you get your work ethic from in
tennis before that who didn't give you
enough attention great question like why
I know that for me in sports it was just
like dad daddy daddy if you know what I
mean Daddy yeah Daddy Daddy Daddy's my
everything yep daddy daddy Daddy's I
mean my husband um yeah we'll talk about
your husband my dad was like my number
one supporter also huge fan of you like
literally texted me and was like I love
Whitney I watched her show is he single
or he I mean we'll see you know he's he
he he loves like women's sports he like
watches the NCAA like he's a coach he
call me and be like Caitlyn Clark is
killing it like he just loves um
underdogs he loves like people I love
that he loves you Whitney he loves like
an
underdog who's like most people don't
like no let's be honest root for women
in comedy are are underdogs in the
beginning now you know we're we're in a
mansion but anyway so my dad loves you
and I wish my dad loved me the way he
loved you mhm but he it was very like
when I'd win he was you know he's so
proud of me and then when I lose I'd be
like I want to do better for my dad is
there a like do we want to like date our
dad like I was like in love with my I
don't know I'm so in love with my dad
and my grandpa but what I was like I
want to think I'm pretty like that's on
is that on me that's again that's where
me and you differ you keep taking it
like a little too far and I can't I
can't agree with you to that point but
I'm kind of like I was my dad's son like
I would I started wearing makeup and my
dad was very he was like why do you have
red you look like a like a clown why do
you red stuff on your face like he he by
the way he knew what it was he the man
he's gas he knew it was lipstick why do
you have red stuff on your face he'd
come up to me and be like like if anyone
says you're not pretty naturally they're
fucking lying but also by the way that's
that's that's the best lineing a guy can
do it's like he's basically saying
you're so much prettier without makeup
on says you're perfect the way you are I
thank you Daddy I can't wait for a man
to see that about me or I could just be
with you forever um no I fully think my
dad is like I also he's hilarious yeah
my charismatic he's a sales guy yeah I
just I I'm like a mo to a fly yep all I
want is laugh and that's all I care
about and then when I'd win he would we'
be like jumping in the parking lot like
rocking he make me watch Rocky movies
and he'd be like you can be a champion
like he created this insane dreamer who
was like you know I can I was always
chasing something but I do think I had a
lot of pressure with tennis but then
with standup I have this Detachment
where now I have this maturity of like I
don't have a dad or a coach or any a
boss who's like putting pressure on me
so now I can talk to myself how I wish
yoube comments I was now it's just the
YouTube com that's your boss what did
the boss say but there what did this
Russian bot have to say about me Drago
like so I've a I I learned from that
like intensity of being a tennis player
and it's still like a solo
entrepreneurial type thing and then I
was like I'm a silly creative person and
then I fell into standup later in life
and now I'm it's like a safe space where
like I'm not
I'm I'm trying to keep my ego out of it
more sure sure sure cuz tennis was very
ego like you either a winner or you're a
fucking loser yeah where comedy I'm
supposed to be like I became a stronger
comic from that difficult audience
tonight
yeah that's true who are you mocking I
would have said I would that's what I
say to myself and I'm very just like
it's you succeed by failing and if
you're not failing a lot you're not
trying out new stuff or being cretive
yes and I've actually had um a club
manager pull me aside once and be like
hey I want you to like bomb more cuz I I
was I wanted to kill every time to prove
that I was like worth it to be there and
he's like we like we love you bomb a
little fuck around moreon stage and that
was like such a cool thing to be able to
have that permission yeah he could have
said it differently um he goes he was
flirting offage yeah that's like saying
you look prettier with that makeup like
you could be not funny too and I would
still accept you I have so many issues
you're like too self-aware
oh like it must be hard true like you're
very you're just very the female brain
you're very smart and it's like a little
unnerving you just read me like a
fucking book that is very nice of you to
say it wasn't a compliment I wasn't a
compl we're
scared I don't I get I I've I here's the
thing about that is like and that makes
me go back to this one comment thing
it's like with like critics and like
reviews if you believe the good you have
to believe the bad also you know what
I'm saying so that's the only thing
where is if you believe the bad you or
if you don't believe the bad you can't
believe the good like that's why I just
stay out of the comment I'm trying to do
this thing and I don't know how it's
spelled or the real definition but
stoicism sure cuz with tennis I was very
huge highs lowest lows and I think
Comics deal with that too where they're
like I'm the fucking greatest who ever
did it and then you have a bad set and
you're like why would anyone give me a
microphone so I'm trying to be very like
can you okay I this is where we differ I
think stoicism is dumb and I'm going to
say it to the camera I can't do it I'm
trying Oh I thought you meant like the
whole thing where all these men now are
like Marcus aurelus and the stoics and
they're all these like quotes that are
um not that profound frankly like barely
a Panda Express Fortune yeah and it's
like a Snapple bottle like be has gotten
me through more than these quotes it's
like a strong man knows how to fish even
when there's no water and you're like
this what huh no no one can hurt you
without your
permission not true that's some Yoda
shit also not true yeah like it's just
none of it it's all so basic and silly
it's like they would rather listen to
men from 2,000 years ago than any woman
now like what are you talking about
everything that was said from ancient
Greece they didn't have phones first of
all they were fucking children so let's
not take any ADV their judgment was sick
they also were hooking up with Children
what are we doing the Roman Empire was
crazy wild they're just horny and like
humping each other the whole time all
the bloods in their dick and they're
writing scriptures yeah also like I'm
good on like these profound quotes Pat
will you pull Christa Stephano and I
argue about this
constantly I'm not even joking read
correct this is what dude stoicism
quotes are for illiterate people cuz
they are so so simple they're just like
don't ask for a light load ask for a
strong back it's Dr SE it's like it's
like Magic School Bus philosophy like
what the fuck are we doing um Mrs
Frizzle for Comics Chris meanwhile I
can't spell his
name what's like shout out to New York
City represent Brooklyn New York I love
okay Chris or no
stoicism oh fuck you I mean that that
photo was like best revenge is to not be
like your enemy hold on sorry hold on is
that true I mean think is it it sounds
good sounds good it sounds yes it's like
live laugh love like what the fuck does
that mean well you go women wrote are
you really confused are you really
confused is that
confusing I mean hold on you go those
are two three verbs that is dumb but I
could defend it like I know where they
were going with that notion like it's
pretty simple
but it's not solving my problems no I
don't think that was the intention you
need to unfollow everyone you follow
hold on hold on hold on be tolerant with
others and strict with yourself like
again like these you could actually make
so many mistakes following these cuz
it's so General and life is so many
variables 100% if a man knows which Port
he sails no wind is favorable oh wait
sorry I got that wrong I made it make
more sense by accident if a man is not
he sails no one is favorable I have an
apartment I don't have a fucking boat if
a man knows not which Port he sails no
wind is favorable pick pick a if you're
not decisive in where you're going good
fortune can't assist you or you can't
you but this is maybe it does make sense
but women we just can't comprehend it
because they're doing like they're
communicating manw with each other why
am I being gaslit by dead pedophile
it's a code that's basically like he who
fears death will never do anything
worthy of a man who is alive it means go
golfing all day and lie to your wife
okay don't fear death like hot T you
know what I'll manually stop like as if
that's such a choice life is very short
and anxious this is all the same guy
this guy did s s s this guy did not shut
the fu how obnoxious must he be with his
friends like it's like he's on another
fucking soapbox how does it help to make
troubles heavier by boning them this
complain this is just men complaining
about what women do you're exactly right
I'm like if you mean boning them you
mean advocating for yourself you mean
living your truth and ex communicating
your boundaries someone rapes you don't
say anything these
are oh no I'm being wild um curb your
desire don't set your heart on so many
things and you will get what you need
have smaller goals hey women stop
wanting to read my attention SP so short
they lost me on the third word I was
like scroll don't explain your
philosophy embody it is this what
stoicism is yes okay I didn't know what
stoicism was when I talked about it
you're you're better off you got Dumber
we got Dumber I feel Dum so confused
about life right now I'm lost I'm lost I
had sh together and now I'm what they
wanted to happen to us questioning
everything they did it to us I meant
like you don't have to you don't try to
chase all these crazy highs and you live
like life is about contentment it's not
about like getting these crazy happy
moments but like learning how to be
content and not putting like too much
pressure on like random is this what
your husband tells you is true so you
don't leave
him that's what marriage is it's like
yeah like below we get it you're
married we got
it loud and clear but anyway yeah I'm
mentally ill hold on just really quick I
I I love the necklace you're wearing
what am I doing but I'm just I I love it
when you do a big swing on a piece of
jewelry and then it's like you have to
kind of babysit it no I I see you kind
of like you're itching it you're you
have I'm fighting for my life in this
necklace right now and I wore it cuz I
wanted Whitney to think I was cool it
was shiny people like shiny things I
wanted to make myself look more
interesting and she can't stop staring
at it she hasn't listened to one word I
said I'm ried I'm on the Ed I looked
like a pirate groupy a pirate side piece
who like gave you like the weird booty
that was like don't be jealous I fuck
the captain you didn't no what I just I
know that we're due for one of these
like a like a I can't breathe right now
should I put on your dog your dog would
look such so cunty she would look so C
don't take you can't bail on it I'm I'm
committing I if I do a big swing on
jewelry I bail like 45 minutes in I
can't do earrings cuz like they really
are pulling us down the patriarchy scale
so you know when you get cornered by
that Aunt at a family gathering and you
feel like you have to bend the truth a
little bit because you have to lie to
family it's like it's in the Bible you
know it's like CU it's like that Aunt
who asks you like when are you getting
married and what's going on with that
promotion and why haven't you moved out
of your mom and dad's basement shed
thing or hi that's my baby in case
you're curious only for her to not
really listen and just judge you because
you know what having a baby doesn't help
people stop asking when are you going to
get married it actually kind of amps it
up I'm shocked well you may have to grin
and bear it with your family you
shouldn't feel that way when talking to
your doctor about that rash that weirdly
looks like your high school crush or
that bump that could be a couple things
but probably is that Keepsake token from
that trip to Vegas or that black spot on
your gums whatever it is Zach do is here
to save the day the place where you can
find in book doctors who will make you
feel comfortable and actually listen to
you and we're not talking about a few
we're talking about tens of thousands of
doctors all with verified patient
reviews so you can make sure the Vibes
are vibing before you ever meet IRL with
Zach do you've got more options then you
know Zach talk is a game changer as you
know I recently 3D printed this child
and he doesn't like that
joke so I had a kid recently and I've
been going to doctor's appointments for
him for the past 10 months but for me
nope of course not so now I'm trying to
catch up like I have this weird mole I
have to deal with I have like a itchy
tooth I got to I I go right on Zach do
two seconds later I feel like I have a
doctor's appointment Zach do is a free
app and website where you can search and
compare highly rated in network doctors
near you and instantly book appointments
with them online once you find the
doctor you want you can book them
immediately no more waiting awkwardly on
hold with a receptionist and these docs
they all have verified reviews from
actual real patients we're talking about
about booking appointments with tens of
thousands of toprated patient reviewed
doctors credible doctors and Specialists
you can filter specifically for the ones
who take your insurance located near you
okay it's the best the typical way time
to see a doctor booked on Zach do is
just between 24 and 72 hours okay I said
two seconds but technically it's around
24 hours that's it that's it you can
even score same day appointments see no
I was right never mind oh he's
eventually right I use this you got to
use it go to Zach do.com Whitney
download the zdoc app for free then find
and book a top rated doctor today that's
Zach do.com Whitney Zach do.com Whitney
hi buddy so let's just let's just cut
the shit Pat finally let's talk about
what everyone else is talking about okay
and I mean
everyone everyone is chattering about my
skin I I don't people keep telling me
that my skin is amazing and let's just
get this out there right now okay it's
the elephant in the living room as I say
my skin looks insanely good
I I don't know what I literally people
are like did you eat your placenta no
I'm not that white okay I started using
a new skincare product it's called
genell genell natural clean free from
mineral oil parins chemicals formulated
by a compounding pharmacist now those
people know what they're doing not some
like
influencer there's like skin care that's
like from some 12-year-old influencer
like hard pass on a wrinkle cream made
by a 12-year-old I'm good this he
actually made it for uh a woman in New
Jersey it's actually kind of an amazing
story and she loved it so much that she
had him keep making it keep making it
and then it became this big company and
you know you know a product works if a
New Jersey woman says that it works okay
these bitches don't lie I'll tell you
that right now of course it's
crueltyfree because you know getting
older as a woman is cruel gen 90 is what
I'm obsessed with it's this new instant
wrinkle cream from genus cell instantly
reduces the appearance of wrinkles
anywhere you use it around the eyes the
forehead the crows feet laugh lines and
it starts working in literally seconds
gen 90 is on sale now at gen usell.com
it's of course included in the
bestseller package order right now at
genucell.com Whitney free shipping on
all orders genucell.com
Whitney I think people think like Comics
who are talking about sex are
promiscuous but I'm like no I'm more
just like being very I'm not hiding
anything I'm talking about all aspects
of sex good and bad cuz sometimes you
think people who are bragging about not
bragging but talking about their pussy a
lot means like I just understand sex I'm
a sex goddess but it's more like I want
to be a mouthpiece to show like
sometimes sex is great but sometimes sex
goes Ary and we all can like figure it
out together so here's the thing that
bothers me when people like female
commans talk about sex okay do you want
to hear us talk about politics is that
what you want so funny I wrote a bit cuz
I was afraid people are G like she just
talks about sex and I wrote it about
abortion and
guns and I don't know if if that's what
they want either no no no no no I but I
also think it's like yeah definitely not
I mean I wrote a bit about War I would I
was like war is crazy you guys war is
wild no war they get all the people and
all the accessories at to one place at
one time men I can't get my five friends
to show up a brunch on time how do they
organize War I'm fascinated by War and I
want to do like 30 minutes they used to
do before email
did any of us have a slack to organize
War how did they even know where to get
like how did you even know what team you
were on how come pigeons like
communicated so well hundreds of years
ago and now pigeons pretend they're dumb
in New York but
like also how come I never see them dead
why is a pigeon never died I've never
seen a dead pigeon in New York they
don't age either they all have beautiful
skin are they real are they like cameras
um uh are they C are they CIA
cameras they're stoic
but like I war is gnarly like when you
think about it I mean it is you have to
get so close to someone to kill them
with a sword like you're in La like you
are you're making out you are get you're
physically yes it's kind like two men
fighting is gay like killing a man with
a sword lowkey gay is so gay it's gay
you're just like like you cared that
much about him to kill him you're like
if I can't have you no one can like what
is you took his life that's fucking gay
gay like what did what what did he have
on you like what did you what did he
have on you what did he know you better
not tell my wife about this also like
inserting gay well everything like guns
are gay it's like a thck it's it's a
dick coming no you're war is gay war is
all just maybe if we start promoting
propaganda that war is gay like menal
stop starting Wars I mean I feel like
they're
fine you know what I mean you're fine
with the level of Wars I feel like
everything like a little war is good
just to keep the drama alive
Sia where's good for L drama I don't
know like honestly like I feel like
humans have a certain amount of savagery
that they require to function or
something and it's always like has to
move right it's like the Roman Coliseum
people went to just like watch people
get torn apart like there's a certain
amount of bullshit that just has to go
down yeah that's why there was so much
violence in your childhood when you were
like throwing eggs at people and stuff
you were like this is my War yeah yeah
yeah yeah well just there there's were
savagery it's like I just got worried
about saying Savages because I got in
trouble for saying it I don't even know
why it's offensive oh because Native
Americans now it is is now saying savage
I was just told I'm not supposed to say
walk in closet because it's against
people that can't
walk poting out why it's offensive uhuh
is the most offensive way to say it but
also do you think I say like my walk-in
closet like you say wi obviously I just
say like my closet like no this was
you're solving a problem that doesn't
exist if you say Walkin closet you
should be canceled it totally someone
was just literally like just FYI I just
heard you can't say Walkin closet I'm
like I've never said that in my life you
fucking loser roll in closet I just I
don't how do you get in the closet I
don't know I don't know but I just was
like I there was such a bigger and then
you can't say master bedroom that's
actually not from slavery I did learn
that it's from the boats it's from the
boats the Mast it was senica on his boat
again two things I never say that now I
know I super can't say them and now like
my T wants to say when you're like don't
say it don't say it okay so War I feel
like we solved the war thing but your
point is yeah like if we're not talking
about sex like we talk we're talking
about our female experience I think it's
this but comedy the whole point of
Comedy is you're saying something that's
taboo yes it's on you guys that women
talking about sex is still taboo but
also there's so many men who have the
most amazing amazing bits I love so much
that are about sex like even like Shane
gillis's last special his sex bit got me
like it was so fucking funny and I'm
like can we all just let each other talk
about sex cuz it's so fun why not but
it's also because there's so much
tension and so much embarrassment and
that's usually where like humor is and
also like and when a woman a woman does
it that's way more tension to be like
malabia yeah and but you know what also
is kind of wild and maybe I'm a weirdo
but women don't talk to each other like
gross about sex the way guys do I feel
like like I don't sit around my
girlfriend like guys I queefed like I
don't even talk to my girlfriends about
I'll talk to complete strangers about it
but I don't like sit around with my
girlfriend and be like so like this
circum uncircumcised dick got caught in
my throat or whatever yeah we're we're
it's too graphic but like on stage we
have that mouthpiece to be like it's
time to talk about some stuff your
mouthpiece is a good name for a special
for you that is a good name also I
watched your um one of your most recent
ones you were on the floor for 75% of
the special yeah that was iconic I'm
tired and you your your knees and all
that like you I've never seen someone
lie like that was incredible and then at
one point you were just sitting talking
is that allow on the ground yeah I was
like she like didn't want to get back up
immediately and you were just like
kneeling on the side and I'm like this
is not stand up this is I'm just there's
a
point cuz also it's I don't remember
what bit was but yeah I do remember
being on the floor and being like if I
stood up and sat back down I will lose
all my power cuz there's nothing like
there's a point and I was like wearing
heels you would have to like there's no
funny way to be like anyway so like you
lose also have you seen Drew Barrymore's
show her talk show she's always on the
floor like they'll start the interview
and the next year know she's just lying
down kind of crying Talking everyone and
it was giving that cuz you know what
you're doing you're taking up space hm
and that's call me
fat that was you took the that yes I
am you were laying like fully on your
stomach at one point just hump it I was
like on my phone I looked up I'm like
how did we get here why are we on your
phone cuz I was Googling your
weight okay wait I want to go back okay
I don't know it's interesting because
it's also like com
doesn't age well regardless you know
what I'm saying so it's like I was
talking about squirting like 8 years ago
or something people like whenit all she
does is talking about sex it's like well
all you do is watch old specials like I
don't know what to tell you know what I
mean it was like at the time that was
something and that is like the token
thing to say also
also don't come no I know don't watch it
so I was has anyone ever you know how
hard it is to watch a female comedian
perform you know how difficult it is to
see a female comedian do a a standup
show like are we are people are female
Comics just running up to you on the
street and being like my buzz like
there's you don't you can go your whole
life never seeing a female comedian
we're basically invisible like we're at
like the House of Blues that's under
construction like they H like we do
shows on like Tuesdays like you never
have to see us when people like all
female Comics talk M off when we go on
stage I'm like did this just break the
second i m d I've never gotten in the
algorithm not one time so like people
talk about like oh female Comics St is
talk about sex like when is the last
time you they saw an ad for like a Nicki
Glazer special They s an ad but it
starts
muted you pressed on mute like you how
did we get here I'm actually not even
that dirty my set like people I think
they assume it's going to be a type of
way it's like I'm just coming up with
whoever thoughts I think will make
people giggle it's not that serious what
can I make people laugh about Stand
Comedy I hate when people take it too
seriously I'm like I I was like killing
with my little niece who's two years old
and I was like this that's comedy like I
was the other people were not doing it I
was like nailing the timing I was doing
like like and she was loving it and in
that moment I was like and that's why
I'm a professional comedian yeah yeah
like it's an energy sure but it's also
like no one's like I think the Three
Stooges are
ha they're just like like what we're
fine with like sound effects we're fine
with like I I've been I had these like
Kevin James like I can fall off a
treadmill too I have these uh I call him
hand on the street but I do these Street
interviews sure and they started doing
well and someone was like that's so
hacky man on the street I'm like I
didn't vent man on the street but like
our podcast hacky everyone has a podcast
but also who hold on who said that well
I could who was it was it Norman
Lear was it Chris Rock like who was it
no do you ever like walk in H&R Block
and there's like four cubicles and
you're like he's doing the same
thing you know what I'm saying you go
into like a Claire's and you're like
there's a Claire's in Minnesota and the
girl sells the same earring like what to
an account and be like you fucking hack
you're using the same fucking W9 as
everyone else you guys this is a oh
you're using a microphone other Comics
do that like what are you doing what
what do you mean but you know what's
interesting I'm coming up with the
algorithm which means I've somehow
cultivated this like like my show can be
like 90% women mhm and their boyfriends
who are like learning like oh this is
fun I actually like to do or like I'll I
make fun of the guys so they'll bring
their boyfriends and the guys like
attention but it's like I I've been very
kind of protected in my up and up where
like I performed for mostly women a lot
in my career weird like you walk in and
it's like a Girl locker room and we're
all just like swinging our panties
around throwing pons it's crazy that's
sick but like you had to do that for me
to even like have the opportunity to get
there huh I had to do what you had to do
comedy like you had to be there for me
to even think I could be there and then
tell girls like yeah comedy is a thing
it's a thing I mean thanks take the
credit okay just take it I don't know
how this works she said something else
downstairs she's like you had to do this
so I could do this and I was just like
did I help you by accident no you did
that was not the goal no but it could
even you could be even as annoying did I
just make it look so easy you're like I
could do that definitely when I watched
the female brain I said if if I can
create what I want to create like she is
I think I could like she made something
no one wanted to see how could I I could
[Laughter]
just I go they paid me to go to this
Premiere I didn't want to be here and it
turned out no everyone watch the female
brain stream it if it's still available
love you seriously I think it's on Hulu
I think yeah it's really oh it's you
know what it is on Malaysia
Airlines they that's so disrespectful
over wherever they believe in gender it
was on Malaysia Airlines and on the
plane that when a ride is that is that
the same did I get it wrong was a
different
Airline cuz the pilot was watching it
and they go fuck this shit I'm turning
straight into the ocean female director
fuck
this no but it's it's the same thing
with sports you have to see women who
you like to be like wait I think I might
want to do that right right right like
her personal life seems to be going so
well
yeah
I like staring at you this is my
necklace I like that we can be silent
together already wait should we just see
how long what we could be silent you go
I think we need a I think we need a
break I don't want to here's the thing I
would normally win that but you played
Sports seriously so I feel like you're
super competitive I am really
competitive me too but I've been very um
it's caused a lot of pain competition in
terms of like losing and being like if
you lose you suck you're horrible and
that's why with standup I've tried to be
like this is a creative Avenue you don't
have to be Cutthroat you don't have to
be hard on yourself like that you don't
have to root against other people and be
more cuz with tennis it was very like I
have to beat that bitch and I actually
didn't like who I was I didn't like
going in the court and like I you had to
fucking it was like boxing I had to like
beat her down emotionally and physically
sure sure so then I was like ibing The
Comedy Store but I really want to just
not do that so it's like it's a choice
it's a mentality and it's cuz I was in
so much intense pain from that comp
competition it's easier for me to be
like you guys can compete about this but
like this isn't competition for me I've
lost to Duke in a tiebreak and then
cried for 4 days like I'm not going to
get upset over this no so it's it is
definitely like just change shifting
perspectives to survive in the Green
Room yeah everyone's like playing their
own game has everyone been nice to you
it's funny you ask me that I PE when I
started comedy kind of wrong sure the
first time I did comedy I did a podcast
show and my friend dared me a podcast
show like a live podcast cuz I had a
podcast and my friend was like I was
writing all these tweets and I was
writing sketches I'd never wanted to be
a stand-up comedian it was not a goal
and my friend was like do 10 minutes of
comedy of standup comedy and like put
all your tweets together some are
premises some are punch punch lines for
this live show so I just go this person
wasn't your friend no and she didn't
know
this person hated you this person had a
shrine of you humiliate you she had a
voodoo doll did she buy you this
necklace oh my God by the way I love
your necklace also this necklace was
made by a female designer who small
maybe that's the
problem men make ones that other people
want to like look
at I'm joking so I so I basically was
like like fuck it I'm going to do 10
minutes of standup comedy in front of a
sold out car lines of 300 people that's
not allowed but when you are when you're
dumb and you don't know the rules it
doesn't seem like a crazy thing to try I
didn't know you should start with like
two minutes I love that you're saying
this because it is just to like timeout
to just be like an inspirational icon
for a second um I love that like cuz
stand up is kind of like the less you
know the better you're going to be I
like it like you know when people are
like I can't I've never learned I don't
know how to write it's like the less you
know how to do it almost the better it's
going to be I also have a problem which
is why I've been fired from multiple
jobs I like hate being controlled I hate
rules if you tell me rules and it is a
little creative brain where like if they
like this is how if you do the
assignment I'll always have to do it
differently and then complain if they
were like you didn't do it right and I'm
like but was it good that's why I think
stand up I love cuz there's no fucking
rules but stand up if you do it like
anyone else that's when you get dinged
like that's the worst thing you can
someone goes this is how you have to do
it I think I'd still be working on 10
minutes right now that's also not even
true you don't have to start with 2
minutes you lawyers there's no like you
have to get this degree in the beginning
all you have to do is get comfortable on
stage D so I tennis I had a lot of
performance anxiety because it was a
really intense thing but I was good at
it but I was miserable so but I was
missing that high of Performing so I was
like I'm going to do it and I remember
before I walked on stage little Doo was
crazy what I was about to do I was like
oh no what if my tennis brain female
brain takes over and I freeze and I feel
like out of body and I get anxiety and I
got on stage and I started doing my
little bits my little tweets and I felt
like I was talking to my friends at
brunch great and I felt this calmness
come over me then at the end of the set
I had some comedy friends that I knew
like I wasn't completely out of the
scene and they were like the best part
of that show was your standup in the
beginning and you have potential if you
want this to work like you got to get
stage time in New York City and that was
the guidance I listened to they just
were like you have to get on stage one
guy was like never say no to a show and
I did that for a little too long um but
I was I was had that like coach
mentality where I'm like just get on
stage and then I wanted to sell tickets
so I had
like I'm going to say 33 minutes and a
Q&A and I just went on the road and then
very early on had an hour cuz I wanted
to make money yeah and cuz I wasn't
making money and then next you know I've
had an hour that I've been cutting and
adding and cutting and adding but it was
a very non-traditional route but a lot
of the comics I think respected the
grind of like how long I've how early I
got an hour and how long I've been doing
it and I think they appreciate it cuz
they know how hard I work and I'm fine
if if they're just like she's just
really hard working I get that a lot
it's I mean look we're going to find
insults in comp every compliment hurts
every compliment hurts my feelings
because it's like you get off stage
someone's like you're such a good writer
and you're
like performer no we're not you know
what I mean like I'll find a way to be
in so when someone's like you work
really hard I'm like I'm not
effortlessly funny you know whatever
you're you're so ambitious I'm like what
the fuck is that supposed to mean but
honestly coming from like the tennis
community where we all were scared of
our dads and just like scared of each
other and then the reality TV community
that was briefly in which is like the
scariest thing I've ever done the comics
were such a breath of fresh air to me
cuz I was like yeah I'm having trouble
with this reality TV show and they made
me laugh so hard about like the reality
of the situation being like you he said
that to you and you said that and they
were making fun of me and I just
remember thinking like oh my god I've
been in this stupid world that takes
itself so seriously and I actually don't
even fit in with these people and they
don't like me and Comics was like the
first time I really was like oh these
are my freaks these are my people so I
actually love the community but then
I've been on the road so much that I I'm
not around enough to get in the drama
like I like to hear the drama but I'm
not I've been on the road the last like
two years so I kind of like I just like
love all the comics like the stand has
really been great to me in New York and
I love that and I love kind of putting
them on too because I have a following
and I love doing the hand of the street
videos with the comics like I really
like building this like Community around
myself because I had a pretty lonely
intense childhood of competition I so
I'm like can we all just be friends yeah
totally totally does everyone do it have
to be so like Cutthroat Like Comics are
kind of like it's inter it's like kind
of just family in a way where shit can
go sideways and people get jealous and I
definitely had the complaints of I would
perform and all these girls would start
to show up and some of the guys didn't
love that like the room would be like
half girls like it wasn't like all girls
I'm sure the male Comics were were
pissed pissed at all the hot young girls
you drew to the crowd just like is
doesn't like the crowd's hanis crowd and
they like don't want to have sex with me
and the ruies aren't hitting tonight you
know the ruies go bad I was like
honestly my crowd will laugh as long as
you don't make a bad rape
joke well yeah that's why they were
mad I know exactly who you're talking
about by the way um but so but I also
for girls going to comedy clubs is not
like a thing they do I think it's a good
date night it's actually true that's
actually go but yeah girls are not just
like what should we do tonight let's go
to a comedy club cuz it doesn't always
feel like a safe space so I like loved
the stand is like cool it has like all
these fancy drinks and I'd be like
espresso Martini night and they'd make
like all these espresso martinis and all
the girls would come but that it's also
kind of like I I don't know is someone
that doesn't go to see comedy cuz I do
it for a living I'd be so curious if I
had like it wasn't in my radar at all or
didn't do it it's like let's go to a
comedy club tonight listen to a bunch of
guys talk about how dumb we are I mean
it is you kind of nailed it you know I
mean you well it is kind of like you
know how Hollywood it was always like
complaining about the annoying wife and
that's just how every show was and then
that's how Comics used to be like I got
married and she's fucking on my tail all
the time and also I don't blame guys
that for the first like 10 years I was
doing stand like why am I going to go
watch Whitney like make fun of men I
mean I make fun of women I make fun of
everybody but it's like I feel like I
had a reputation for like totally get it
but I also every now and then you see a
male comic that you're like his
perspective is really interesting and
fun to me and that's where I think guys
can enjoy our comedy I always say that
guys feel like they're in the female
locker room being like I didn't know a
woman felt like that when you're
cuddling her or like I didn't know that
she thought of that so it is pretty it's
educational um but I do like having a
safe space for the girls to feel like
they can come to a comedy club and not
feel like they're not meant to be there
totally yeah awesome I love everything
you're saying except safe space we need
a new term
um safe space I said it you have to say
it with a list
SP a i SP I feel like this is not a safe
space for me right now I was told by an
intern at a TV show that it was not a
safe space cuz I said Merry Christmas so
I'm triggered by the word safe
space um okay you've been touring for
two years does this take a toll on your
marriage good question um I feel like it
keeps it fresh is it it's a fine
question it wasn't that good no I it
keeps it fresh and like we kind of like
taking breaks from each other I I feel
like if you have a 9 to5 you have to
battle that like do we become roommates
where this is very like he's a comic he
gets it and we're we love to talk on the
phone like we don't shut up so it's like
a constant phone call and then we are
both pretty independent on our own like
he's been single he's never been married
before before and was that a red flag I
I red flag is so zech I you know but I
think cuz he was like a a com he's a
comic in Ireland he was pretty big like
I understood like yeah he tored his
whole life like I kind of get how a guy
could not be married and he jokes that
he's like a sweater where you're like oh
this looks really nice and you put it on
you're like okay not perfect but I get
it little chunky a little chunky but
it's like he feels like home to me he's
my dad love that he's a he's a New
Yorker I'm a New Yorker we both do
comedy he's he's how much older he's 14
years older than me but I'm also I'm 32
I don't recommend like early 20s like I
make my own money I don't need him he
doesn't need me
it's very like okay cool I like you as
my like my partner he gives me great
advice and we really don't our
identities are not each other at all
like you're interdependent not
codependent yeah and I think I've it
took me a while to be ready to even be
in that kind of relationship and yeah he
does remind me of like a lot of my
family members and I feel like you end
up being with someone that feels
familiar to you I love older it's toxic
oh
why is it like I'm toxically attracted
to older men it's like it's so hot to me
I'm not dating an older man right now um
like I love like old
tattoos I'm dead like wait you want to
fuck a pirate and that's why you're
jealous yeah it's you got me always
projection wait an old tattoo I love
like old tattoos that like have been
there for a long time and like like
there's like a mole with a hair coming
out of it on like a it's probably skin
cancer but he doesn't care don't care
but it's like on a portrait of his
daughter you know I love like an old
like girlfriend from a secret family
that he forgot about one of the many he
forgot about like I love an old like
girlfriend's name from like the late 70
I love like a like Donna like what he
has so many lives before you I always on
our wedding day we gave speeches cuz he
lived in Ireland most of his life and I
guess it's an Irish thing to give a
speech and I I kind of was like oh I I
sometimes I'm sad I never saw him grow
up or like was there for when he was
like younger like in his 20s when he was
like becoming who he is but then I
remember I'd be in kindergarten if we
met at that time but I I like to use
like uh dogs to compare it it's like
younger guys are like puppy dogs that
you can adopt who are like super excited
they always have a little red boner
they're peeing everywhere you can't
control but they're so cute but you're
also like you're fucking annoying a
little yeah yeah and then older dogs
like they're smoking a cigarette playing
poker they've been pre-trained they're
not jumping on your couch you know they
you don't have to teach him about like
anything he knows where to use the
bathroom he knows where your clit is
like you and I'm not a caretaker I'm not
going from your mom to me I'm not taking
care of shit I don't even do laundry and
he's been self-sufficient to this time
so I'm like good now we're just like now
we have an apartment love that we don't
spend a lot of time in love and what do
you I've always struggled with dating
older guys like what do you get them as
a GI like they have so they have
everything they need God I'm actually so
bad at like a
colonoscopy Advil yeah a lot of Advil he
actually loves unscented moisturizer he
goes nuts AC Cetaphil in your
stocking get he's like don't get me
scented cuz he's Irish and some do he
use like the Chapstick that's like black
the medicated why does every dad have
that they always lose it but it always
doesn't have the wrap on it it's just
white and then you open it and it's that
pink and you're like a man it just
smells like medicine it's like Vick's
Vapor Rub you're like what is this fuck
out of here you to kiss them and you're
like I wish you smoke cigarettes
actually it smells like
medicine so let's get to it guys let's
talk about gter gter makes $25 active
sunglasses I love these sunglasses
because they don't slip which means I
guess they're active they don't bounce
they're 100% polarized good where have
you been all that life I love having
lots of sunglasses I need I I truly need
a pair for the car my purse my the
garage my living room every pocket of
every jacket so I don't have to be that
dork who wears them around my neck do
you know what I mean and everyone's like
hey Auntie Coachella I don't need that
do you have any cough drops hey hey I
don't need you mocking me okay just
because I have one pair of sunglasses
that's overpriced I need sunglasses
everywhere because you know that your
girl doesn't want eye wrinkles from
squinting cuz crow's feet is for the
birds I tell you but why are are
sunglasses $400 in what world is someone
spending that kind of money on
sunglasses like why gter solves all my
problems because I have to wear sunnies
at all times because I cannot tolerate
eye contact with another human I did it
once and now I have it
g these glasses are ridiculously cute
they're also lightweight comfortable
100% polarized if you're active if
you're running they don't slip or bounce
like jerks easy to clean unlike some
jerk Brands we know why gter the name of
the glasses are also really cute I got
the one they're called donkey goggles
they're orange and blue and uh super
cute and then there's one called fast as
shell fast as shell which is like
tortoise and blue lenses they are so
cute jeans white tank top colorful gter
sunnies Fashion Icon instantly they're
so cute you don't even have to have a
personality they'll do all the work for
you so if you want to support the show
and pick up a pair good is giving good
for you listeners free shipping on your
first order you can go to good
g.com Whitney use the code Whitney to
get free shipping yes that's a baby good
offers a 30-day moneyback guarantee and
100% satisfaction find your pair at
goodgod
r.com Whitney and use promo code Whitney
to get free shipping oh hello good for
you listeners I love you um also I
somehow won the lottery and I get to
talk about the one thing that actually
matters to me yes there's a baby right
here you do too baby I swear but like
let's be honest Etsy Etsy is I think
it's my religion what is that what you
would call it I'm just saying if you
need gifts Etsy is your guide there's a
new thing called gift mode on Etsy it's
here to take the stress out of gifting
so you can find the perfect item for
anyone and any occasion now it's easy to
find gifts made by independent sellers
for all the people in your life like the
pickle ball or the Jazz guy the Zen
Seeker yoga person the artist or the
like pasta lover you know someone who
makes like like bread their life they're
like I'm sourdough lady down you're like
all right whatever you need etsy's got
you wall decor drink and bar Weare serve
wear cookwar rice platters cutting
boards throw blankets candles Linens
outdoor grill accessories necklaces
bracelets Rings earrings pajamas robes
handbags wallets jackets coats sweaters
knits slippers clutches and overnight
and duffel bags I actually just bought a
diaper bag on there and then these
little clear bags to go within the
diaper bags you can't use plastic
grocery bags for diaper bags learn that
the hard way for some reason in January
all my friends have birthdays so I'm
just like gifting my head off at the
moment a gifting moment is always around
the corner sneaks up on you especially
after Christmas when you think you're
out of the woods you're never out of the
woods but whether it's a birthday
anniversary holiday or even just a day
to say thank you gift mode on Etsy has
got you covered okay do you need to find
the perfect gift don't panic try gift
mode Now by on
etsy.com see he's panicking I said don't
panic and he was like what panic I know
we got so many of your baby clothes on
Etsy didn't
we
oh so he loves skiing which is shock the
hardest part about our relationship I so
here's the thing about skiing I retired
I quit it I quit it good I have
boundaries good I just it's two hours uh
to get the shit on to get in the thing
to go up the thing forget it's like
$1,800 for all the dumb the costume
they're like how do the shoes feel and
you're like they're killing me and they
go perfect it's amazing you're going to
have a great time out in the freezing
ice clo also for me you can't win at it
so I don't fucking get what we're doing
you're fighting for your life down a
mountain and then they're like cool do
it again but also 2 hours get up the
thing for what two minutes of and then
then what I that was it I chucked myself
down a mountain cuz I was done with it
and I like basically broke my hand cuz I
was like I'm done why do we all have to
like like spend all this money watch all
these documentary have all these like
sports events so men can
go for two minutes surfing dude I had I
watched that the 100 foot wave I just
couldn't stop watching Bethany Hamilton
lost an arm because of some men who were
B
and want to feel like kings or queens
and gods also get out of the ocean
that's someone else's house true okay
that's a a shark safe space that you're
invading correct that's where they pee
oh it's also the okay so the
beach the beach is okay I don't do the
beach either neither do I I don't
understand why people don't realize that
sand is blonde
dirt it's not people like think sand is
like beautiful beautiful it's dirt it's
dirtier than dirt people pee in it they
stand it they put their feet in it
they're like naked on it so right do you
know what I'm saying and then it's like
in every crevice it's dirt right and
then you go in the ocean which is like
someone else's is urine it is urine
right people okay so I watched this
documentary of 100 foot wave it's like
four episodes on
HBO I watched it of this guy who's just
like how am I going to and I was like H
and we got to and talk about running
from your real problems he's getting
like new joints put in like his he may
pass away like it I'm like why he died
four times in the documentary and his
wife was like can you just come home and
like take the kids to school once his
children are just they have dreadlocks
they're like can we go to the barber
like they're just like starv it's crazy
what people do to feel something we yeah
we for how long yeah I wake up with so
much anxiety like I don't need to go on
a roller coaster I don't need to have
any like near life death experiences
like I feel like I'm going to die all
the time just like existing in my own
head no well I'm just like there's
enough stress why would you add to it
with a thrill of like actual death sure
sure sure I don't I don't need those I
also like don't do any drugs oh that's
me either anymore like I I can't I joke
like I took a melatonin once and I'm
like this is my iasa like it was crazy
it was 48 hours I like didn't know my
mom was like do you need to go to rehab
that's so so have you ever done I I
haven't done cocaine heroin obviously
I've never done
meth what else is there I've I smoked
weed and I will like ruin parties like
I'll cry I get really in my head and
then I did cocaine once in my bachette
party and I did one what a wild time to
do cocaine no I don't know what was
happening but is it a hit I don't even
know what it is I did a a bump I did a
bumpy and immediately started just
gushing blood through my nose and like I
was like I'm an angel F all for sure you
just had a Stigmata like I am the people
around me were like maybe let's not
maybe that's a sign let's not so
I I'm trying
to so you know I thought I was going to
be like Johnny Deb was going to come out
somewhere make out with me and instead
everyone was like that's disgusting it's
all over my white
dress that is so it was so bad but like
I just I also just feel like I have
enough time controlling my own mind
why fuck it up more and I think it's a
control thing too I'm very about like I
was in sports you're not allowed to do
drug you're getting drug test all the
time but I do think but I think most
people probably do drugs to get the kind
of like Focus Clarity
energy that you already have playing
sports or to be as funny as you are you
know what I mean people was my drug and
stand up is my drug so it's it's defin
stand Up's my therapy don't ever say
that again when
sorry it's my safe space I'm sorry I
just I feel like so safe time I feel
safe is when I'm harassing boyfriends
doing crowd work and telling them that
their mustache is stupid here's what I
will say smoking weed I had to stop
because I it makes your anxiety worse
had a manic
episode long story short long story
short I had it a year I had a psychotic
break you guys all saw it um my wait was
that the the dyed hair time no that was
that was me that was just a choice I
made uh sober but you like could pull
off a lot of Shades and I got a little
jealous I thank you your skin tone can
pull off more shades not all of them
that's really yeah I wouldn't do it
again it got real carrot I was like oh
she okay no she did it I can't even this
is all I can do I look back at the time
that I had colored hair it was during a
pandemic and I did have friends that
were hair artists that were losing their
health insurance and it was like I could
have just like given them a th000 bucks
I you ruined all their
careers they're like can you stop
posting they like I can never work in
this industry again Whitney they they
think whatever hair dye I put on you
poisoned your brain they're like uh you
did Winnie's hair and then she started
stuttering but they for sure were
sometimes you were like turn at this
color and they were like we don't
recommend you do that and you like push
them yeah I was yeah I mean no one does
green it wasn't recommended yeah no one
does green um and I was like but if you
mix this and this and they're like yeah
no we're not going to do that for you I
was like but he me um have a ombre gray
they're like you shouldn't and so what
am I saying psychotic break but I also
like didn't realize how mainstream
people perceived me as that doesn't
sound I didn't say it perfectly like
Madison Sinclair awesome comic said to
me I was like why does everyone think I
was like losing my mind when I dyed my
hair blw like why is that so wild and
she was like it would be as if Jay Leno
dyed his hair BL blue yeah and I was
like I'm trying to like put myself in
the shoes like if she just like you're a
professional like if Sarah Silverman all
of a sudden had pink hair I'd be like
yeah huh yeah she okay yeah you do look
put together in general so I guess like
it was like is she is she going through
something sure cuz like right now you
could I feel like you could be president
like with your glasses and like your
hair back it's very so you're saying
that I can't put a sentence together and
I'm really really old and probably had a
facelift and can't walk up a flight of
stairs that was the meanest thing I've
ever said to
anyone fucked that was it's been a
pleasure
I'm what did you just call me
[Laughter]
unqualified the gum on the bottom of my
foot could be president right now I mean
literally dude you just you look like a
CEO you a CEO okay thank you not one
that does like illegal stuff or or maybe
yeah yeah like like one that just gets
hired to like be the performative like
the they like hired a woman just who's
not totally qualified just to seem
Progressive right you're the bar CEO
okay thank you thank you like cuz what
is it called when they a company is
already tanking they usually bring a
woman in to be the CEO oh to just be
like she run to the ground totally
toally we tried we did everything it's
like it's like a real thing uh like
isn't the Twitter CEO SE uh a woman CEO
now oh God I think so I know the poor
woman I know fighting just fighting so
hold on back up back up okay drugs here
psychotic don't don't conflate those she
goes I started reading people's minds
yeah no one is cool one is sad okay you
got my grandma's speaking to me right
now yeah one's cool the other one
involved me trying to track down the
Scientology ships um
would you honestly I'm interested by way
came pretty close to finding shell m
scavage i mean me during my psychotic
episode like I did get a lot done it was
like big Matthew MCC in season one of
True Detective ever so productive you go
am I manic right now dude well that's
what happened I was like editing five
shows I like made three specials people
are doing interventions I'm like I'm
like if you think I am losing my mind on
drugs maybe you should try doing these
drugs you honestly you guys sound
jealous I
know you're jealous sorry I'm booked and
busy while looking like this and you
can't book one gig that's crazy maybe
you should take whatever you think I'm
on California weed I have a hot I do
think weed should not be legal in
California we made a mistake we had we
tried it we tried it so the homeless
people have roller skates and machetes
unhoused the you know what no no I
reject it I reject this
unhoused unhoused like who is that for
am I so that I don't offend the meth
heads that would stab me in the spleen
without thinking twice what who's this
for we need to be more respectful of the
guy that's shit on my
car are you sure like La is wild the
unhoused
by the way this is America no one can
afford a house this America we're all on
house I'm voting for you for president
I'm
America this is America I have an
apartment and I want a house tell me the
difference between homeless and unhoused
oh God
homeless unhoused unhoused is also hard
out of the mouth unhoused unhoused I
just like unlocked my jaw that's where
we
differ I can say it I just don't think I
should have
to she go my mouth is very flexible but
I do like I do like you're like I don't
say the N word cuz it's like hard to say
um that's not the reason one too many
syllables like when there is something
to change it to that's not the reason to
boycott like you know what I mean don't
make my mouth work hard transgender it's
just not I prefer TR doesn't roll off
the
tongue I like the way your priorities
are n God didn't want us to say it that
way that's why he designed our mouths
like
this ah I hate that shit I'm sorry don't
no don't where why did we get here okay
right um so your marriage okay so can I
ask you a question how do you do it how
also I do have to say I am still fresh
like I was only I've only been married
two years we got engaged after six
months okay Co years can I ask you when
he proposed did you right when he did it
did your brain think about doing a bit
or a
joke oh good question he kind of did a
bit in our proposal what was it so when
we first were dating he would
psych actually the whole time I was like
is this a fucking bit I actually would
send him like just engagement rings as a
bit like as a joke cuz I was like I kind
of just want a little one and then I was
like I want an emad one with two
diamonds and he you already talked about
getting engaged we did that jokey thing
where he's like I'm going to marry you
one day and I'm like yeah we'll get me
this ring and then it just the bit kept
going that's why I think like don't be
afraid like if he's scared in the
beginning of that like I don't give a
fuck I he was the one though that's like
I was ready to play games cuz I'm like
he's a comic he's clearly going to break
my heart or be crazy and he immediately
was like oh um if you want to play games
that's fine like I'm just kind of tired
and I don't want to deal with that and I
literally was like I'm so sorry like I
that's hot that was really hot he has a
thyroid condition
yeah he doesn't have a lot of time laps
yeah yeah correct so he's just straight
up and I was like oh my God this is hot
and then he would send me videos cuz I
was filming a TV show of him singing
funny songs based on like the fights I
was having in the house so he would like
make up a funny song and it just to try
to make me stop crying he really fell in
love with me during the darkest moment
of me like being locked in a house
filming reality TV Sum House this is
summer house so you're like you're not
okay you're like filming all day you're
everyone's Playing Tricks on you you're
not sure what's going on you think
everyone's trying to like take you down
so I was in like talk about loving you
at your worst like I cried a lot on the
phone with him and I'm actually like not
even a crier so it is crazy that he kind
of saw me in this like real psychotic
break what makes you cry um ooh what
makes me cry when I feel really out of
control okay and I think that was
reality TV where I was like I feel the
pieces moving in places and I don't know
what's going on and I'm scared um and I
also think like when you're a sports
person like like there's I have a little
bit of obsession with like fairness oh
my God that's my problem I'm all about
Justice and when I feel like justice is
not correct I I don't know how to handle
it when I feel like people are wronged
or if I'm wronged and then I overreact
I'm I'm or like when people do mean
things to me that I wouldn't do to them
so I was in a very when people don't
play fair yes you're cheating actually
tennis like when someone would cheat me
I would have a full mental breakdown
sobbing lose focus and my mom's like
just accept when they cheat it's part of
the game and I'm like beat me the right
way but it's also this that's the one
place it's supposed to be a meritocracy
is sports do you know what I mean to
have rules and so yeah but why would you
work this hard and be this good and then
cheat like my thing with cheating is you
you'll always know you cheated so that's
when I I would rather come in second
cheating is a huge thing in tennis cuz
in junior how do you cheat in tennis
well in juniors you watch now nowadays
they actually have automated line calls
but there's normally a judge but in
juniors they don't have judges on every
Court we're calling our own lines and we
have scholarships on the line we have
money on the line we have sponsorships
so people are just like out out and it's
crazy so I used to there's a rule like
if they hook you they called hooking you
can hook them right back and then you're
even hooking is when like I the only way
to get an abortion and
America so
sorry hly that was really well done
thank you yeah I really actually loved
that so there's this cheating element of
it but I always felt what's hooking
hooking means like I hit a serve this is
an educational podcast I hit a serve
it's is a sports podcast I hit a serve
it was an ace I won the point and you go
that bow was out so you literally take
the point from me so then I would wait
until it was an important point and i'
do it right back to you but this is
mental Warfare and and I when I was
younger I used to do it more and then I
realized like just don't and I had this
like Karma idea in my head I was always
was like if you don't cheat like in the
long run it'll work out and and the
world is fair and I realize the world
isn't fair but you can choose how you
react to the world is kind of where I
got to and how like being mad at people
and angry is literally just hurting
yourself and having an older wiser man
help me with that like he's sober he's
been through a lot of therapy so I
really like I like respected his mind
you need to be someone who respect their
mind yes I love that I love all that I'm
hearing because I realize that like what
I need to be with someone is to respect
them and if I see someone who's not in
control of themselves or their reactions
I lose respect and then I can't have sex
with them anymore I that makes complete
sense and I need someone that's like I'm
in awe of yes and I also used to be be
with guys just for like looks I was very
into just being with hot guys cuz I
didn't respect them so then they
couldn't hurt me so I so I would or I'd
be with really emotionally unavailable
men cuz I'm like they're not even
available really I wasn't a available so
then I I kind of had this thing cuz I
was protecting myself and I'm
competitive so I had a lot of Pride I
was like you're another fucking hurt me
like no one would ever break up with me
and I would just always be on top and
it's like love is not a game and he was
the first one that was like we're not
playing a game I just I like spending
time with you and like let's get to know
each other so that was like hot yeah um
the hardest thing about dating an older
man who's smart is like he's experienced
something so he'll tell me like you
shouldn't do this and I'm like I need to
make those mistakes on my own I love
that so that's our biggest like he'll be
like I told you so and I'm like don't
fucking say that cuz like now I get it Y
and I you also know I don't like being
told what to do so I'm like let me live
My Crazy Life totally and learn and I'm
I love that you're here for me but I
can't like listen to the rules of all
yeah yeah you have to make the mistake
or there's no such thing as mistakes um
unless unless you're me in the pandemic
um you have you respect of someone's
mind is huge so yeah when he proposed he
obviously stopped sending me cute cute
videos cuz he stopped trying as hard but
like 6 months in I wake up and he's like
singing in the other room and he's was
making one of these videos and he texted
it to me and I opened it up and at the
end he was like by the bed and just like
gave me the ring and the bed is my
favorite place like that's where I did
always imagine getting proposed to
that's called clinical depression I had
my invis just crusty eyes you're just
like the grandpa from Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory
I was
like and I remember crying one cuz I
wanted to cry cuz I thought that's what
you're supposed to do and two but I feel
like when I try I can't I know I started
crying for a deeper meaning which was
this is something I tried the least
at yeah and I was like I called my mom
and I was like I tried the least my
whole life I'm trying so hard to
accomplish things and with him I didn't
try I actually arguably fucked up a lot
like I was really like
not my best self a lot of it yeah and I
go and it still happened and it like
spun how I thought of the world because
I thought you had to be so fucking
diligent and so fucking right to get any
kind of wins in life things have to be
hard in order to be good yes and that's
what I learned that's why I thought with
tennis like I had to torture myself so I
cried over the fact that oh something
cool happened that I didn't plan like I
didn't trick them I didn't have like a
lot like I actually didn't see it coming
and then but also I was a little stoic
with it where like it didn't make my
life like I it was it was very like this
is cool and now let's continue
living it was not like filling the
godsize hole God no I feel like you
didn't I didn't meet him till I realized
like men are actually like really
distracting and they hurt my mental
health and I really don't want to get
involved with one if he's going to like
put a toll on me and annoy me and
distract me from my goals but when it's
easy and healthy it's just like you're
my you're my teammate and let's just
continue had to have a couple really bad
ones to be like oh it's actually like
I'd rather be single a bazillion times
over than be with the wrong but when
you're ready to be single on your own
that's when you're like a complete
person and can attract a complete person
yeah you know and he also his mom had
passed away and I think he was in a new
mindset too where I think before that he
like had a really close relationship
with her and like she was sick and all
this stuff so I think he was in a time
of his life where he felt like he had
space for love it's like a weird timing
thing sure of course but I also feel
like like anything if if you hold it too
tight it'll leave you whatever you chase
you chase away any Letterman was
actually joking about that with money to
me and we were like being money
manifestation and she was trying to tell
me that's why she bought all her purses
and I was like okay but I I actually it
makes sense we're like tennis I wanted
to win so bad I would lose okay say it
again okay so Annie believes that buying
Louis Vuitton person
will make more money be in her bank
account she said basically if you're
holding on to the money too tight that
the money is not going to flow the right
way and the more you spend the more you
make and I was like I'm cheap I'm a
cheap person and I was get stressed out
when I feel like I'm getting ripped off
and stuff I believe in investing and
like whatever and she was telling me
this and I was like I've never heard
something like this before no any okay I
like yes and no she was a little
high
like not off her rocker but I she was a
tiny bit high if someone is wearing a
Louis Vuitton purse around at all times
there there's drugs in it uh okay it
looked so fucking good I think she was
convincing herself the pur was worth it
no I think that yeah I know I'm like
sometimes when someone's explaining
their philosophy on life to me like that
I'm like are you trying to convince me
or yourself because I'm you're never
going to sell me on this but like but it
is a mindset it's like when you're
getting a job if you want the job so bad
they can sense it off you where you're
kind of like if you want me here great
if not like I have other opportunities I
wouldn't hire that person but I I yes
and no okay agree I think that when you
come in and you're like have a needy
desperate energy that's like bad news
but I think it's important to be like I
really want to work here yeah I really
want this job I'm not going to want it
so badly that I can't even have a
conversation and be myself and I think
that's the relationship want but when
someone comes in and is like too cool
for school they're like I could take it
or leave it dating a fuck boy yeah I'm
like this bitch is going to ask to work
from home this bitch is like going to be
like can I leave early for my improv
class like I'm like if this relation if
I got divorced like that would be
fucking horrible yeah but I'm going to
be okay but I also have to watch myself
because people that like could care less
about me I'm like Daddy Daddy Daddy so
when someone's too nonchalant I have to
check my conditioning cuz I'm just like
magnetically attracted to that person
and when someone's like I want to be
here and I like you and I want to be
with you I'm like so like I have that
emotional dyslexia I do think with money
I'm with you like you have to have faith
in yourself but I also you know like the
first year that I made money I thought
when you had $100 you had $100 yeah when
if you have $100 you get to keep like 60
of it let's say yeah exactly California
so 20 cents and so I couldn't afford my
taxes that year and I like went broke
the year that I made M I had a full
panic attack uh like 60 days ago over
I'm also big on going like like don't
spend money on literally anything buy
everything on eBay everything on Etsy I
don't buy anything new and it's also
like you start think when you have too
much stuff it actually gives me anxiety
cuz you just feel weighed down by it but
it's funny what you said with the like
the guys who hate you versus the guys
who are obsessed with you I actually had
that pendulum where I'd be with the guy
who didn't care if I got hit by a car
and it would be I was like he doesn't
even like being around me why is he
telling me he loves me like and he would
just just not these guys they just
didn't appreciate like they're
narcissists right but they say I love
you but you don't feel but you feel
horrible around them this is my thing
about I just had this conversation tell
me if this is nuts I think the way we
say I love you is backwards I think
because when someone says like I love
you if you don't feel loved it's just a
weird lie yeah and it's it's like he
loved what I was on paper for him sure
he was like oh yeah I like that she did
this she went to this school she played
Sports she's she's funny but I'm like
but we're not in love
but like like yeah like checks all the
boxes but like not like no con you feel
like you're sabotaging it cuz you're
like I don't feel that and he's giving
me love but love is a action but it's
also totally but it's also like the love
you're giving I'm not able to feel for
whatever reason maybe you're just
missing each other insert an annoying
love language attachment style you know
when you feel empty or with someone was
what I'd feel and then I'd go to the
opposite spectrum and be with a guy that
like I could be like can you do my
laundry and he would do it and he would
just he would never leave me he would
like lick my pussy all day if I wanted
like but you don't respect him and then
I would go back to the narcissist who
didn't respect me and Dez was this first
guy that I had this kind of balance with
which we're we're very like maybe some
days I have more of a crush on him and
some days he's more of a crush on me
like it's pretty balanced some girls
love being with a guy who like loves
them more like I still need a little
Chase like I'm I have daddy issues I
like that you know that about yourself
yeah he's a Scorpio like he's tough and
I and I like that but you what are you
you're chasing your husband around your
studio apartment well I mean yeah we
can't go anywhere I feel I feel like as
I don't have this like I don't have this
guy who's like he respects himself
around me like it okay and I like that
dignity yeah dignity this thing called
digity there is a like balance and I
think it's like good to know that like
it's possible to find that it doesn't
have to be but I do think to recover
from a narcissist you go to a guy who's
like so not and then you keep flipping
back and forth and it's like your head's
banging against the wall and it's not
even hot only way I can come yeah
so but I do think like this is my new
Theory cuz like this guy that I'm seeing
really like like it's always like when
is the I love you think going to happen
and my thing is like I'll let you know
when you love me like I'll let you know
when I feel loved you don't have to
worry about saying it yeah you guys will
say it by accident all the time and by
the way dude when they're fucking you
they're just like and that has never
happened to me not
once wait maybe there's something too
your jewelry choices how what do you
mean guys say that during sex I think it
happen sometimes in the moment or like
not one
time
what I get like
slut like what because I'm the one
that's like don't push me around I'm
just like I just am a princess and
they're like I love you is that okay can
I please fuck you I'm like I don't want
to do anal and they're like I love
you I'm like I just can't but wait do
you feel like when you get married cuz I
it does it's such a stereotype but do
you feel like when you get married sex
gets weirder I think there's something
about it getting hotter oh it's hot I
think so too there's a calmness to it
the day after we got married there's
just a calmness of like oh this is kind
of cool like we chose each other and now
we just get to like is that how you have
sex you're just like I like him like
like
I why are you like Tina at the wedding
just like like in the corner just like
like who invite did anyone invite her we
don't know I think she works here we
don't know her I do feel like I'm in a
BDSM outfit now but I do feel like the
our marriage it was pretty calm and I
actually he wanted to do anal and I told
him after you got married I told him not
till we're married cuz I had to get him
we had to play some games sure and then
our wedding night I was like do you want
to do he's like I'm not doing it on our
wedding night weding night CU I knew
he'd say no and then I was like you just
rejected me so now whenever he asks I'm
like why don't you just reject me again
so I'm just playing a long game of like
trying not to do anal with my
husband wait hold on on your wedding
night you sprung that on him I was like
joking about it and then he obviously
was like I'm not trying anal at like 2
a.m. when you're drunk and like just ate
cake for 4 hours pretty sure your dad's
like next door I can hear your parents
in the room so he said no and now I'm
like oh so I'm a little pooor to you
like you don't even want this pooor I
just I don't know where that came
from I don't know where that came from
but I felt like a dirty little poopo
that he was like no I don't want to do
ano with you like when a guy says no
when you've offered it it's like we're
done here I like that by the way you and
I both look into the camera we're not
even talking to each other we have not
made eye contact this entire show we
like to be like this is where we did
anyway like we're both doing our own
show with that
said you're now the host of the good for
you V do you need me to should I even be
here I've never had a guest just talk
straight to the camera most of the inter
dating is
crazy
[Music]
dating I still going to get this off my
chest oh fuck this is just a solo
podcast in this way
oh I'm
dying wait can you move your chair a
little you literally like in my
shot I'm wheezing oh God I'm wheezing
yeah I'm a Leo ah that
actually makes
sense I well you know my thing on
astrology is I don't think it's like the
stars and stuff but I do think the
proximity of your birthday to other
holidays or lack thereof forms your
personality yeah Leo's always were like
it's a summer you didn't get to have a
birthday party with people and you had
to like figure out a way to get
attention in all and you're like
sunshine and you had to like entertain
yourself yes yeah I'm like it's I would
love to be cool enough to be like I
don't believe in astrology but I do yeah
and I don't know how it works I'm into I
want I enjoy I enjoy it I enjoy it it's
a very fun hobby you can use it at the
bars if like a guy up to you he's not
into you just be like what's your sign
and he'll be like Virgo and you go we're
not compatible and he'll be upset for
multiple reasons why are you compatible
with viros oh I'm not why not um cuz
it's actually close to Leo if you're
touching apparently it's not good and
just I've had multiple Virgos in my life
and it didn't work out so I blamed the
Stars sure as a Virgo um I get women I'm
good women I'm great with yeah men viros
I don't I don't think I've ever met a
man like I like a woman cancer don't
like a I know I don't think men are born
in September Virgo men are gay gay well
we're yeah as a gay man I you identify
as a gay agree because September was
back to school so my birthday September
4th that was weird first day of school
so I got like for my birthday I got like
a protractor and like pencils and a
protractor you know what I'm saying I
use it for sex so so like it was all
about just like acade like you know what
I mean my f my birthday was the first
day of school on like a Tuesday MH mhm
there was no like celebrating yeah
whereas you were just like at
like August I was like August the
party's here August 12th there is
something about like like it's so cute
when humans try to connect because I
think we spend so much time being like
oh you were for this team you're dead to
me oh you voted for this person you're
trash like tell this is what humans do
with their birthdays though like what's
your birthday you're just like talking
to a stranger what's your birthday
August 12th August
29th a day we both were born on the day
like not even that close I'll make
anything make sense why did we like what
like not even we did that over text I
was like I am a Virgo Moon so I
understand you I understand you yeah you
work hard what else won't you do in bed
I'm entertained by this oh um I don't
like spitting I do not like choking like
it's hard enough to come I'm not going
to come while I'm fighting for my life
sure and but so but hold on hold on
but are you and I'm getting choked by my
necklace right now I was going to say
the fact you just tried
to come Fort like something that choking
you one thing choking and giving you
tetus you'll pay for it um but are guys
doing it so much that you can't breathe
I joke that it's hard for the men to cuz
like if they do it too hard you're
scared to do too soft you're like pussy
as bitch so like it's it's you're like
making me act I just I don't need to be
like scared to suffocate I apparently
it's science that like you can have a
better orgasm while you're
suffocating it's the thing where like I
am on so many like I scare myself
through like competition trying to be
the best person I could be I just wanted
to be like relaxing and like peaceful
and like it's probably from my past but
like I just I don't want to do drama in
the bedroom and like if my lower back's
hurting a little we're
going like a I'm also strong like I'm
physically strong by way I think I agree
like that's why I don't like spitting I
don't like choking I don't want slapping
I don't want hair pulling ah I don't
want you turning into a different person
having like a different voice or being
like baby or being like just be the guy
that I like was with 10 minutes ago who
now like wants to connect with me in a
physical way yeah yeah so that's
actually pretty kinky just like like
missionary and I I'll do lights on I
like lights on what I'll do lights on
I'm like let's fucking let's little are
you let me guess no music
no know Psychopathic I like like sober
like my life it's like I want to feel it
all and I don't need the extra bit it's
like slapping is Like Cocaine like I
don't need the extra stuff I just want
the rawness cuz it makes your nose B I
don't want condoms yeah I just want raw
simple and like authentic and if I Cry I
Cry I couldn't do you think I'm a Freak
no I just I'm trying to reconcile how
different we are and how much I like you
oh my god do you know what I'm saying
you're going to make me cry I love
meeting someone that we're almost
different in every one of our
preferences but I like you more do you
know what I mean well cuz we're both
bored with ourselves so when you find
someone wait I'm what I'm bored with
myself so it's fascinating I am on the
edge of my seat every day with what I'm
going to do next like I have Whiplash I
riveted by myself but it's fun to talk
to someone with a different perspective
and not be like that's correct well no I
think so many people or it makes for a
good podcast yeah they yeah no good
you're this is this is Money in the Bank
that's why I like you not like as a
friend I just mean like this is going to
do nothing
you're like babe this is analytics I
mean yeah sorry the advertisers are
going to love it we're never going to
speak again okay lose my number we have
good chemistry is what I'm trying to say
I feel like you came to play you like
fucking you got you got the show yeah
but also if we had seen each other last
night we would have spent the whole time
being like save it no we would have told
each other shut up the whole time I'm
the worst to don't blow it and then
you'll be like we have to try that again
and it wouldn't work don't talk it was
just it was a nice to for you to even
acknowledge that I was in town yes I
like you a lot thank you I like um
burner phone has my pod with my husband
named her podcast with her husband with
her last name like a feminist
should I'm a d you have I'm actually
freaking but no but I say don't spit on
me don't spit on me it is so dumb to be
like I just lay here with no music in
the daylight you can't touch me you
can't choke me you can't spit on me you
can't do anything you can't Las me you
laser me you're lucky to be here yeah
just you're welcome you know it's cuz it
I had another podcast that I didn't have
time for guests so then it turned into
another one so I was like you're coming
into my pod sure it's burner phone and
it's a funny pun sure sure sure I agree
no it's good I like it thank you I love
that you just did that it's a funny pun
no it's not that I actually don't like
puns I think I hate puns I hate puns but
when they're good they're great yeah but
I would never do a great pun people like
them yeah and we don't yuck people's
yums um and I you've said that a couple
times I don't totally know what it means
but I like it I don't know what it means
got it got
it okay this has to end I like you too
much um uh also giggly Squad you already
know you're touring oh yeah Han
b.edu what are we on here go
G.G I end these very awkwardly anything
else you'd like to say to the camera why
are you look at me all said I'm thrown
cuz you're looking at me I know you're
actually uncomfortable by the way this
whole time I keep taking my glasses off
cuz I like can't believe what I'm seeing
like you're W look back in your camera I
literally who what who are you why are
we at theable I know like how did I get
here like what no anyway sorry let me
let me make eye contact with the true
intimacy I understand um I end these
awkwardly okay bye don't ride elephants
I love you guys Hannah burner we did it
[Music]
n